hey guys mkbhd here back with another
video review and today we have the cyber
acoustics ca 5402 6-piece speaker system
this is a high-wattage premium speaker
system with 5.1 channel surround sound
that comes with a couple of awesome
accessories that you might want to also
check out
these speakers retail for around in
about 60 dollars which is going to put
them in that range where you're going to
get the most bang for your buck taking a
little closer look at the system here
you can see that there are five
satellite speakers and one subwoofer and
all the satellite speakers are identical
so you can place them wherever you want
without worrying about which one is
which and they all have the same
one-inch driver in the middle
you can see when you buy the speaker
system you're not only going to get the
speakers themselves but on the left here
you can see i have what's called the
control pod which i'll get into a little
bit later which allows for volume
adjustment and things like that and
you're also going to get an mp3 cradle
to hold your mp3 player say if you have
something like a zoom hd or an ipod you
can easily put it in here and connected
via an included audio cable quite simply
put the cyber acoustic system is an
elegant and good looking and very simple
5.1 channel surround sound system
that'll probably fit in your budget if
you're looking for a home media center
pc
some speakers to go with that taking a
look at the included control pod you'll
get a mute switch headphone out
auxiliary in a base volume control and
on the top a master volume that switches
from left to right and actually glows
when the speaker system itself is on one
thing i didn't like about this control
pod is that it was a little bit light
and can move around on your desk in the
slightest movements the satellites
themselves are magnetically shielded and
as you can see here they are all the
same identical driver which is a one
inch which will give you really nice
highs but the mids might be a little bit
washed out now it's not to say these
speakers won't be good for music as a
matter of fact they are really good with
the highs and they're really good with
the subwoofer which gives a lot of kick
now taking a look at the form factor of
the speakers themselves here you can see
that the center channel speaker which is
only one of is actually a nice thin form
factor you can put it underneath a
monitor or behind something if you don't
want it in sight it's really small
enough that it won't make a big
difference on your desk now like i
mentioned earlier the four other
satellite speakers i told you about are
actually identical and they also have a
nice relatively thin form factor for
what they are what they're doing they
have a nice one inch driver and they can
also be placed on your desk pretty much
anywhere you want as they're pretty thin
so you can put it to the left and to the
right of two monitors or a single
monitor and you can put the other ones
behind you and they'll really be out of
sight no matter what you want to do with
them
overall i gotta say the form factor is
definitely my favorite thing about these
speakers all right now we've arrived at
the main attraction which i think is the
most important and most impressive part
of the speaker system and that's the
subwoofer which is 9.25 inches tall 6.25
inches wide and 7.5 inches deep and
produces some really rich deep bass and
i'm really impressed with the speaker
system subwoofer now i would have loved
to play some music for you guys to
demonstrate this but unfortunately it
would really just be a test of your own
speakers youtube's compression my video
editor and youtube's copyright finding
so i'm not really going to get into that
either way looking at the back of the
subwoofer you're going to get all your
included cables but taking a look at the
ins and outs you have your input for the
front rear and center channel speakers
and as we scroll down a little bit here
you'll see the connection to the control
pod which plugs in then you get all your
outputs to all your different speakers
which all plug into the subwoofer and of
course your power switch
also when we zoom out here you'll see
this high quality subwoofer also has a
humongous air hole and that's where
you're going to get your kick it works
best if you put it up against a wall so
if you have it on your floor put it up
close to a wall so you can really feel
the base one last thing that's worth
noting about these cyber acoustic
speakers and also a large a number of
other cyber acoustic speakers they tend
to do this is they include an mp3 cable
an mp3 cradle so you can actually go
ahead and plug in your zoom hd or if you
have an ipod or iphone you can use that
too and this is actually what i used to
test the highs mids and lows of these
speakers overall just to wrap it all up
i really like these speakers if i have
to give them a rating from 1 to 10 i
would give them a 7 and a half
typically speaking the tip the frequency
response of these speakers and any
speaker system with the subwoofer is
much accentuated on the low end and on
the very high end so you're not going to
get that the best mids but if you if you
trust me on this the highs are very
crisp from five satellite speakers and
these are going to be absolutely
excellent for listening to music if
that's all you do with your speakers so
this has been mkbhd with a video review
of the cyber acoustics 5.1 channel
surround sound system thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one